so i wanted to start
with the development of this new movie
was there ever a point when you
considered
continuing this franchise in the
anthology format or did you always know
that film number two was going to
continue ben and zoe's story
i wanted i wanted to do something
radically different to be honest
initially i wanted to do a villain
origin
story i knew that i wanted to do a zoe
ben revenge story but i really tr
i wanted to do sort of like a behind the
scenes
father-daughter like puzzle maker story
the problem is
i i what i found was splitting that into
two different story lines was just too
much content too much story to tell
it would have to be its own uh its own
one
one-off as an anthology and i i it was
just it was pushing up a boulder uphill
you know what i mean to try to get that
done
and i think look in you know maybe down
the line
what i also should say is like as much
as the audience wants to know behind the
scenes and who minos is the more you
dramatize them like even if you had
anthony hopkins
it still lessens their mystique and it's
better to keep them veiled and i think i
had to learn that a bit the hard way
i'll put it that way
um and and then with this movie i think
the cool thing is like we
expand the world you know the idea that
it's not just that one game in chicago
that we saw in the first movie it's
happening all over the world
that your your entire life is unreliable
that maybe you don't have agency over
the choices you make like i think after
the pandemic in particular
like we all feel that like maybe there's
a supernatural force
influencing our lives and taking things
away from us and
so so i think that's what i'm hoping the
audience will take away from it
this idea of free will and you know do
we really have agency
over our lives so that that that i think
is in there
and the sequel also has some cool twists
that sort of reveal
how draconian and screwed up minos
really is
oh i want to get to some of that but
first i wanted to revisit the idea of
figuring out whether viewers want to
watch
people solve the puzzles in escape rooms
versus actually participating in them
themselves is there anything you learned
from the audience reaction to film one
that you found yourself using to create
these new rooms in film too
you know look i'll be completely candid
this was really rushed and i would have
loved more time
because like one of the things that
we've got from market research is that
people really enjoy participating in the
game
the problem with that premise is the
pacing of a movie
really suffers if i'm cutting to a
close-up of a clue
and you're looking no no go over there
go over there you're you're ahead of the
you're ahead of the characters right and
so it's that fine line of like you want
you want that breakneck pace but you
also want to give these easter eggs so
it's i i don't know that i completely
nailed it
um because uh you know it was it was
definitely a fast and furious process
but it's tricky it's tricky you have to
set up a very clear visual goal
in each room what's that what's the
threat how does it kill you
how does the room work you know um and
in a typical escape room
you know you have five or six people and
i find something hey i found a doorknob
and yeah
i got this weird matchbook and it's it's
not linear right it's like
and then oh that thing you found 10
minutes ago let's oh yeah that fits into
here
here in a movie you can't do that you
got to keep the pacing you get it
so it's much more linear in that sense
and i think that's the other
thing that is tricky with these movies
is like how do you
how do you keep the audience in the in
the sort of moment to moment like what's
the each goal what are they looking for
because it's
it gets boring you know if somebody's
just like looking through stuff it like
you know you're falling asleep right and
so that so
and that and i think also because the
rooms change so much and they're
constantly transforming like the beach
starts like a beautiful cape cod beach
and by the end it's like this blue you
know technicolor
kind of like dream world where it's
collapsing in on itself and so
i think keeping the the spaces
constantly changing and unreliable as
part of that as well
now i just want more and more and more i
am rooting for this one you know how
much i love the first one and now i had
a blast with this again so adam huge
congratulations to you and
hurry up and make number three uh i i so
enjoyed talking with you on the first
one and
thank you i appreciate that it's it's
very it's very kind of you